alright well that was nice we talked
about a couple of video games because
let's be honest we're gonna be talking
about one video game for the most of
today's show a before we do that Michael
mehar d a you're a person who enjoys
civilizations you were currently in one
right now you're flying to another one
pretty soon yeah and then to another one
after that yeah Germany gamescom and
then back to another one can you blow it
doesn't have a civilization set Sudan
they said I was iris about actually
that's a no what let's not get into that
one particularly touchy subject ah but a
civilization six you played you see
little coy look down cuz i forgot which
101 yeah mmm first number one in a while
now right yes what five or something and
they yeah they went too often that
they're beyond Earth any there was an
expansion for that as well rising tide
anti Jenna late last year was the earth
yes i was october i think last year okay
so yeah if your access I mean they put
out XCOM as well a couple months back so
they're no strangers to putting up big
games at but civilization 6 first one a
while I guess the sort of this is the
fur accents or tarling yeah I mean it's
the most basic question now first of all
what is new in this one because it looks
relatively familiar and the only major
difference I've seen so far as right
into cities yeah they're doing what they
call unstacking cities so it's hard to
talk about civilization about selling
boring but like aside for people that
don't love it so essentially the city is
used to be on one hex tile on these maps
like these chessboard maps now instead
of like every time you build new
building throughout your entire play
through which could last like eight
hours the university's the barracks
won't all go on one tile there would be
these different districts that go up
like you're taking on more than one tile
so it's actually one of those things
that affects way more than you might
think Rob Handler and I both played
about four hours 150 turns and it took
us four hours do that because we were
learning so many new things are you
doing but you know it [ __ ] of five on
stack military units so you can't just
have this massive army on this one tile
of death they called it right now the
cities you'll have to wait until you
build like a campus district so you can
build a university you know like an
observatory the science the actual
buildings you know same thing with in
camp
it's you'll build an encampment then you
can build like the barracks and the
actual like training grounds for
soldiers what this does is not only
makes you consider the map more because
you get adjacency bonuses so if you
build an aqueduct next to a river but
also next to a university it's gonna get
bonus oh cool I'm so the observatory
like up high on a mountain exactly if
you build a campus next to a mountain
range like you'll you'll get a bonus for
tier science output so so that kind of
record you to put a city close to a
bunch of other stuff yeah so you want to
group certain things like encampments do
really well on their own though because
this actually affects the military
strategy the game I'm not traditionally
military player I like culture like four
people on familiar civilization
essentially you just like build up like
Hollywood you build up your
entertainment industry you build up your
great artists thinkers use these people
to pretty much influence other
civilizations to follow you I kind of
idolize you but military now instead of
just attacking one city tile and laying
siege to that it's a little more
strategic because if you're near these
two mountain ranges you can put in a cam
it right between them like Thermopylae
and kind of close the gap yeah so not
only do you have to attack the city but
you also have to worry about troops
coming out of the encampment right um
and then if you look at a city and you
know for a fact if your spies are
telling you that like Marseille is a
science & klein city and it's giving up
the French Catherine de Medici in this
game she's not French she's cool story
behind her but yeah it's all Ian yeah
but she like married into the French
royal family in that late Lorenzo sister
maybe everyone it was Lorenzo Lorenzo I
know a guy named Lorenzo that works at a
vapianos yeah hey Donna Donna um likes
to blow those sweet coils yeah does that
work I don't know so talk about no man's
sky yet I can't so you'll attack a city
you'll know that's a huge scientific
city and there they have a lot of
advanced technology so you big I'm going
from our sake and I can see they have a
really flourishing campus district as
well as a few wonders which of their own
tile as well oh so you can take the city
and take all that stuff as well you can
you can attack certain districts at a
time before you even get to the palace
okay so that's where it becomes receipt
if you want to just halt their
scientific production without actually
eliminating them and using the military
force you just take their campus
district defend it hold it that's cool
and that'll like boost you in science um
same thing with like I don't know like
aqueducts if it's a huge city that's
populations like booming the aqueducts
are some house yeah if it's a naval city
I think there's a Dockyard district I
don't know did a bunch we didn't try but
it makes you consider the map
more down the road because each city's a
little more specialized than one of the
main tenants with tenants with
civilization 6 that for access is going
for is making each playthrough different
which sounds like a marketing thing but
this thing is with civ 5 you could
essentially follow the same pattern if
you want it to toward victory every time
yes this there's another thing that
during with us not just the unstacking
cities but active research which
essentially functions like this list of
side quests which there already were in
step 5 but now you know you'll be
researching a new technology and it'll
tell you right under it what you could
do to boost that so you have to wait
like five or ten less turns will just
change if you're like researching
construction if you happen to build a
quarry in that time it'll just give you
the technology so what I found in those
four hours three or four hours we were
playing every turn there was much more
to consider but there's also less
waiting this time around a lot of
problems that every civilization game as
structurally is that the first like 100
turns are really fun you're figuring out
where you want to go to civilization the
last hundred turns or that victory rush
when everybody's gone for cultural
economic scientific victories but those
middle turns can kind of get boring
because you're having like you might be
like in this battle up north but also
waiting those 12 turns for like you know
space exploration now there's just with
that active research side quest tab you
can keep boosting things that will also
make you maybe branch out of your
comfort zone unstacking cities more to
consider when you're attacking defending
cities and just when you're building
them in general so the fact that they're
designing around the pillar of making
each playthrough different actually rang
true for the few hours we played it was
Rob's first civilization I think he
found the same thing he was learning not
just sixes new rules but with the
cessation foundation yeah totally I mean
even when you're talking about these
games like this is these are the
conversations we have yeah it's like
this two ways of this conversation is
one with people who know about civ yeah
which is like this super you know
there's like a bunch people on the
chopped probably being like what is any
of his me I am so I guess for newcomers
do you think it's in any way less you
know I feel like XCOM was one of those
great games that like broke people into
a genre they may not have otherwise
touched you know the the reboot of that
game was perfect from fans like me who
love the old games but also like God me
know we're accessible enough as well and
it's not even like can you do that with
civ is there anything about this game
that's like more accessible i mean the
how it looks already i think it's
probably a bit more yeah yeah I
yeah it's like combination of
civilization revolution the council
versus art style with civ 5 but they
wanted more character to it because yeah
I think it was at beach the Li designer
so that actually one more like
behind-the-scenes thing is really
exciting with this is that the two
expansions for civ five brave new world
and gods and kings were like widely
lauded and like they are said to have
made civ5 the game it should have been
and launched the teams that made those
expansions combined and they're making
six and the the credit that's him he's
leading this up sid meier's not attached
to this he's just like a supervisor like
as usual lately um but they are stands
behind him whipping yeah exactly Moria
just like pretending an idea what says
no I'm kidding seems like it crazy
paradise she's a very nice guy yeah um
he is they're essentially I it's cool
because they're making a new game the
foundation not editing an existing game
now so it will see what they're doing
but yeah they're one of the things every
civilization is potentially a new the
first civilization for somebody like Rob
handler in this case and there there are
tutorials in place but they're also kind
of the fact that it's different like
each turn there's a lot more to consider
they said the learning curve is actually
a little easier because you're not doing
these things in the first under turns
and being like I have no idea what I
just did and then having these boring
mill turns and then I come into victory
rush you like what the hell is happening
it's kind of like easing you into it so
yeah you'll probably have to play like
10 hours before you start really getting
the loop but that's like one of the
rewarding things about the game it's
still entertaining because you know you
have espionage if diplomacy to not go
too deep into diplomacy is really good
now because they've always tried to make
these other leaders characters and
themselves that you can actually
interact with and like manipulate and
figure it out but now they have
historical agenda so like Teddy
Roosevelt will always do the speak
softly carry a big stick like he'll roll
you if you're too close with borders but
he will fight you but they also have
hidden agendas you have to figure out
yourself through spies or just what
they're doing so if you know like kimchi
Wang I think the Chinese leader is um
like building a lot of settlers you'd be
like okay he's trying to expand now I
got to take up the real estate while I
have time right so it's really there's a
lot of things feeding into this that
seem minor at first but actually have
these ripple effects that kind of affect
the overall like turn to turn and like
play through to play through rhythm of
the game it's cool stuff yeah
civilization 6 peter brown hi when the
first civilization comment first
civilization came out
1991 okay ask for this yep it's working
yeah I was gonna say its 25th year
anniversary this year oh really yeah
okay you know that nice work that's
impressive thank you it's my 25th year
anniversary this year he's about to say
how old it was all the civilization that
was that was the setup but you just did
it for me yet when when were you born in
nineteen anyone September 22nd forceps a
month same birthday as bilbo and frodo
baggins my kidding I'm not kidding I'm
not kidding people you go to Europe are
looking not real I'll go your son
impressive I'll go to Europe I guess you
friends were born the same day as Hitler
what days and we're not the same day the
same year same day be weird I didn't go
to school to like 80 year old German
your friends are born the same year
domin same as same berhad the same birth
date other same birthday is Randall
Cunningham go Eagles what I think yeah
save is just slightly older than you
September than anyone probably I'm
guessing not the start the peppers I guy
was I kicked off the fall release
scheduled a first came out Mike mehar d
like march is the fall of baby is being
born that's like when all my friends
were Barnes March March my family to a
bunch of songs I soon summer lovin yeah
yeah I was old New Year's babe oh
nevermind i hope my mom's not watching
this haha ok well we just ask her you
just ask her when she yeah Pat I was a
happy accident same me tell ya six units
siblings our way six yes six years after
my brother I I asked if I was an
accident and the responses know you're a
bonus ah now my dad let her to use the
phrase happy accident so Lisi said that
goes know you were a mistake
civilizations sakes house soon October
21st same base battlefield one same days
bath filled one and hitler's birthday
there you go folks it's definitely not I
don't think is it close let's check it
out we can cut that segment off like
already if there's oh no April twentieth
okay I got excited cuz it's all 20 it
actually was about six months away as
far as you can possibly go
you